más democracia cero sanciones es la
propuesta del presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro para manejar la crisis
política y económica de su país vecino
Venezuela con este objetivo realizará
una conferencia internacional en Bogotá
convocaré en Colombia una conferencia
internacional con el fin de construir la
hoja de ruta que permite el diálogo
político efectivo de la sociedad y el
gobierno venezolano además durante su
visita la casa blanca prevista para el
21 de abril planteará Joe biden el
levantamiento de las sanciones que pesan
sobre el gobierno de Caracas Estados
Unidos es el país que más sanciona se ha
impuesto a funcionarios públicos
venezolanos y a la Industria petrolera
del país caribeño sector que ha dejado
de recibir 232 mil millones de dólares
en el último año según el presidente
Nicolás Maduro por lo que el mandatario
venezolano agradece la propuesta de su
homólogo Petro un diálogo para superar
los problemas de los venezolanos y sobre
todo sobre todo
para pasar la página de este periodo
tortuoso de persecución económica
financiera de medidas coercitivas
unilaterales de sanciones pasar la
página de este tiempo
de sanciones y persecuciones económico y
bloqueo contra Venezuela aunque no hay
una voluntad Clara el año pasado biden
permitió que la empresa estadounidense
Chevron volviera a operar en Venezuela
pero la iniciativa de Petro genera
también descontentos en una carta
dirigida al líder de la Casa Blanca el
expresidente colombiano Andrés pastrana
tildó al gobierno colombiano de caótico
y denunció la participación del gobierno
venezolano en el tráfico de drogas esta
política hace metástasis en Venezuela
con cárteles propios enquistados en su
gobierno y protegidos por él Desde la
oposición venezolana también han
expresado su descontento según varias
ong en Venezuela hay entre 240 y 310
personas deten idas de forma arbitraria
por motivos políticos